hi in this video we're going to be
learning about typescript why it's
useful how it's going to increase your
productivity and how to implement it in
your react projects first I want to
start with a couple of pros or
advantages of using typescript number
one the biggest one is interfaces this
is the main reason why I use typescript
interfaces are like sort of some sort of
types there are not exactly types but
there you can you might as well consider
them types they let us tell our code
what types that we expect from our
objects and what their properties should
be so it gives us some sort of like
predictability to our code and protects
us from some errors and gives us the
ability to work with different libraries
as long as we specify way we expect so
for example if I would tell a react
component look I'm expecting in my props
to have a property age that's a number
if we don't pass this property it's
gonna complain and if we wanna pass an
age value of John Doe it's gonna be like
no that's not a number so it kind of
protects us from the little mistakes we
can make number two is additive support
this is a big one for especially for
beginners and the intellisense and the
autocomplete can be really useful at
times let's say you had a massive
interface and your interface had let's
say it's called user and it had age
number I don't know age name address and
you can just say when you're creating as
something of type user you can just hit
control space and it will tell you all
you're expecting a number and you
expecting rather an age and address all
this stuff so it's really cool the
autocomplete can be useful number three
is it's a JavaScript superset if you've
read anything about typescript you would
have heard about people referring to it
as a JavaScript superset because that's
what it is
you're essentially just writing
JavaScript plus some other stuff which
is really cool what's cool about it you
can just write JavaScript the way you
did it and add some things on the top of
course we have static type checking now
javascript is dynamically typed even
though under the hood really in
JavaScript there are types but they're
just not enforced in the language itself
but in typescript
in a lot of cases you would you have to
specify your types to protect yourself
against certain runtime errors now I
have to mention a couple of not
disadvantages necessarily but I would
say these are situational cons number
one is extra code you have to write some
extra code when you're typing typescript
and that can be a bit of a hassle at the
beginning and you can you have to
specify types you have to add some code
for your react components for you have
to write some interfaces for your props
and state it can be a bit of a hassle at
the beginning number two is that it's it
could be unnecessary for small projects
to be honest if you have like a small
project in and you have just a couple of
components and you know the type of data
that you're handling then it's I don't
think it's it's necessary the typescript
is labeled as the JavaScript scales and
it's made for bigger applications and it
can be a bit annoying to get into
because at the beginning you don't know
what the types of some of the variables
or objects that you're using you have to
Google sometimes some types and you have
to install some types libraries to run
certain frameworks alright enough of the
theory so let's start actually
implementing it with a react I'm
assuming you already have no J's
installed to use NPM and create react up
as well if not go ahead and install
those and let's go here on the desktop
and I'm gonna open up a terminal window
I'm gonna say create - react - up I'm
gonna call it TS react and here we need
to add the flag typescript so - -
typescript which will now scaffold this
as a typescript react application by
installing the normal react dependencies
+ installing the typescript types and
I'll be back once this is done
okay now that it's done installing we
can just close this and open this
yes code and off the go we get this TS
config file which specifies a couple of
things for the linter for the typescript
linter and and this config file has gone
so much better in the recent months it
used to be much more strict and you can
edit this to your level of strictness
that you want you can google typescript
linter and TS config and customize it
however you want I'm gonna leave it as
this for now if you can see in the
package.json we have their usual
dependencies plus these types now you're
gonna come across across a lot of types
using typescript because whenever you
use the library you need to go along and
install the types if it's not written
already in typescript so let's go to our
source folder and as you see here our
unusual files are now PSX instead of
javascript which just changes the way
the editor you know intelligence is them
I'm gonna remove this logo because we're
not gonna use it I'm gonna remove all of
this inside the app I'm gonna use a
component and what I want to do for this
is just a simple search thing if you
look at the poky API we just used this
URL this endpoint or base URL and we add
slash Pokemon slash the name of the
pokemon we want I'm gonna get a bunch of
data like you can go to postman here
I've already searched for Bulbasaur and
what I'm interested in is abilities and
base experience and of course you can
extend it how are you much you want one
as well get the picture of of this
Pokemon and I think this is in sprites
yeah so sprites here if you look at
front default if I click on this it
gives me a picture of Bulbasaur so I'm
gonna try to extract these four things
and show them on the app alright so here
I'm gonna put a component which we
haven't created yet I'm gonna call it
pokemons search
and off the go it's already with the red
squiggly saying we can't find it in
JavaScript it wouldn't complain until
you run but here it complains because
this doesn't exist actually so let's
remove this logo and let's say import
Pokemon search from I'm gonna put this
in components components yeah we haven't
created that folder yet slash Pokemon
search let's create a folder called
components and here we'll create pokemon
pokemon search dot TSX all right we can
still use the normal type script or
react snippet so RCE is gonna create a
class based component and here i want to
get some details about whoever's using
this so I want to get their name and how
many pokemons they have and we can pass
these from here so but how we gonna pass
them as props but in typescript we need
to specify the type of props so here if
I hover over component it tells me that
I can give the type of the props and the
state so the P and s so here I can do
like this and I can say that the type of
my props will have a name and it's gonna
be a string and then a number of
pokemons which is gonna be a number so
now I can go here and here there's
already a red line saying like oh you
didn't give what this component is
expecting so here I can I need to say
name and let's say this is John Doe and
the number and this is cool it already
suggests s' what we need which is really
cool I can just press ENTER and here
let's say John has five pokemons and now
all those red lines go away and now I
can actually compile and run my app so
let's for an NPM start
it runs without any problems and
actually we're not doing anything with
these props yet so let's let's actually
do that I'm gonna put this live back to
what it was and here I'm gonna have a
paragraph saying user I'm gonna use the
props so let's actually extract first
those properties so I need these
structure them so say constant name and
number of pokemons and they're already
suggested for me and we're gonna get
them from this top props and here we
will say user and concatenate the name
and here we can say has and concatenate
number of pokemons and say pokemons
let's save and let's go to our app go as
user John Doe has five pokemons which is
the data that we gave now let's say we
don't wanna like maybe user has no
pokemons and doesn't give us like a
number so we can actually make this so
right here this we can make it optional
and we can as well change this let's say
we need this type of props and other
components we can make this more modular
by by putting the interface here or
actually just having in a folder on its
own so we can use there in other
components so let's create a folder
called interfaces and I like to use so
let's call this user I like to use this
convention by adding the extension
interface so interface so user interface
dot TS and here I just want to export
the interfaces export the fault
oops default interface and this is the
user and here we're gonna have a name so
the same as we did name of that's a
string and here we will have the number
of pokemons which is a number now we can
make this optional by adding a question
mark here so here what we we cannot
chillie just admit this and not have a
number of pokemons and it's still gonna
be fine
actually yeah actually I need to bring
this in first so here let's say import
user from I go back one level to
interface this slash user dot interface
and here we can just say that the props
are of type user like this and now this
wouldn't complain that we emitted the
number of pokemons because it's optional
and here we can do so let's just take
all of this and cut it or like all of
this and we can check so because if we
don't have them it's gonna be null what
we need to do we can say number of
pokemons oops number of pokemons
so if this exists then we can just
return this and actually we can need to
wrap it in a span it's not spawn span
and put all of this so if we have a
number of pokemons we show we show that
if not we don't so let's save all files
and here it just says user John Doe and
if I go back and add the number of
pokemons it will say has five pokemons
cool so let's not add a an input field
where we can search for a Pokemon and
see results so let's go to our Pokemon
search and under this paragraph I'm
gonna put an input of type text and I'm
gonna I'm not gonna use the controlled
component I'm gonna use the reference
instead to find this input and submit
the data so the reference will be this
dot it's called a Pokemon reference ref
like this it's gonna complain because
this variable doesn't exist yet
and here we're gonna have a button it's
gonna have an on click and let's call
this this dot on search click and let's
give it a class so we can style it my
button
and here we'll say search let's go to
the app CSS
I just want to override the we don't
need these actually and the logo stuff I
just want to override the basic button
style so here I'm gonna say dot my
button I'm just gonna give it some
border so one pixel solid just I'm just
gonna say blue and just give it a
background or is it back ground of a
background color rather of just white
alright let's go back to the component
now we need to create this on search
click and we need to initialize this
pokemon reference so am I gonna say
Pokemon Pokemon ref and to give it a
type so this will be the react dot
reference object this is gonna be of
type HTML HTML input oops
input element and don't freak out I
don't just know this you can go Google
all your reference types and stuff like
this and initialize them here it says
property Pokemon ref has no initializer
yeah so we need to actually initialize
we can't just leave it just declared
like that so in the constructor
constructor so let's have a constructor
and this will take a props and our props
are of type user and inside the
constructor a constructor which is gonna
call super props and here we need to
initialize our pokemon reference so this
top pokemon reference and we need to say
it's a react squad react or create
reference and now this will initialize
it as a react a reference and now we
need to have some states because we need
to store some variables after we search
for a Pokemon so let's say this that's
oops dot state equals and here we're
gonna have the details that we need from
the Pokemon search so like the name of
the Pokemon and we're gonna initialize
this to to be empty we're also gonna get
the number of abilities number of
abilities I'm gonna set this to
initially to be null and the base
experience set this to null initially
and we're gonna need the image URL or
call it image URL is the the front
sprite thing which is gonna be is
actually not at the type an empty string
and we need to actually give the state a
type so here here we're gonna create
another interface let's call this
interface let's call a search state and
this will have the name which is oops
it's gonna be a string it's gonna have
the number of abilities which it's gonna
be a number I'm gonna have the base
experience which is gonna be a number
and we're gonna have the image URL which
is gonna be a string as well and here we
just had a Conner and we say search
state ok says null is not assignable to
type number let's just assign them 0 for
now doesn't doesn't really matter here
we need to create this on search click
so let's create that so on search click
it's not gonna take anything and it's
gonna so we need to get the value that's
inside of the input so we have a
reference to it we can say Const input
value equals this dot pokemon reference
the current value and this is just react
stuff here it complains it says object
is possible
Knowle okay so I I know the get around
around this this is a TS length problem
we can just add a key here saying what
is it
strict strict
yeah strict null checks this makes sure
that we don't have any value that could
be null
we can just set this to false because in
our state we don't have any way of
knowing so we could just set it to false
and this should be gone
actually I misspelled it here it's a
lowercase u okay that warning is gone
now so we can actually carry on so here
we can now send the request to our API
to the API endpoint so I'm gonna use the
fetch method which is just JavaScript
and do back back back ticks to have a
template string and say HTTP slash a I'm
just gonna copy it from postman so it's
this endpoint and here we need to
concatenate the what we input it so here
with the dollar sign curly braces input
value and here we say then I'm gonna
have a result and here the way fetch
works is that if we don't have a
successful result it doesn't go to the
catch so we need to do to have a check
for it we will do if result dot status
there's not equal 200 then we just set
so we just do this dot set state and we
need to set an error so set error to
true and actually we need to add this
error property so here for our state
we're gonna have we might have an error
so let's say error of type boolean and
we need to initialize it by default the
error is false
and here we set error to true we also
need to return now else if we don't have
an error we need to say rest on Jason
which as well return the promise when
you need to chain and then here and we
can chain it down here but it's going to
cause a problem if you don't have an
error is just gonna proceed and cause a
problem so we need to change the dot
then right here and here it's gonna
return us some data and inside of here
now if we have one we have the data we
need to bind it to the state data we
need to say this dot set state and here
we also need to set the earth to false
in case it was true and every we need to
set the name to data name and the number
of abilities to data dot abilities we
get an array of abilities so we access
the number of abilities by doing data
the abilities the length and we also
need the base experience
oops base experience and this will be
data dot base underscore experience and
this is in the API by the way if you
wondering where I'm getting this from
and we need the image URL which is going
to be data to pry up sprites dot what is
the front default yeah this is it
alright so now we need to show them in
our action in our markup so here we can
we need to distract them from the state
so see if we do the equals this state
and we go back here we do a control
space and we get actual autocomplete
which is called so we need the so we
need the error and we need the name the
number of abilities what else base
experience oops not base base experience
and the image URL is a problem with name
our because of course there's a conflict
in variables so this we can say we can
name it use a name like this and then
give username right here like that so
now we're gonna have a dynamic markup
here in case we have an error so here
let's say result markup and up here we
need to say we need to initialize let
result result markup and we can actually
leave it without a type here so it's
it's not the the it's not that strict
that it always requires us to specify
types
now here we we first check if we have an
error because if we only check if we
have one of these things then we might
have both so we check if we have an
error then we say result markup equals
just have a paragraph and we say Pokemon
not found please try again else I say
result markup equals and hey let's do it
div let's have an image and the source
of the image will be the image URL alt
will be let's just say Pokemon let's
give this a class name of Pokemon image
and I give this some styling and here
we'll have a paragraph or there's a
problem here oh it's because I didn't
close the string oops
alright so here in the paragraph we need
to say name of the Pokemon has and
concatenate the number of the abilities
so number of abilities and say ability
is
and we need to say the base experience
sell and base experience and say base
experience points all right I want to
style the image just gonna give it some
margin so here let's say I am G Pokemon
image give it a margin top of 20 pixels
and a margin bottom of 10 pixels
alright let's save all files and let's
see what this looks like
okay so we already get this oh it's
because we already have some details
like some initialized details or what we
need to do actually we need to
encapsulate all of these in a certain
type as well so what's cool about this
we can we can as well nest interfaces so
here we can say interface Pokemon so
this is what a Pokemon would have and it
would have these properties right here
so we can just cut them and paste them
here and our state will have a Pokemon
of type Pokemon like this and here we
instead of putting this stuff here we
can just say our Pokemon is initially
null and when we get here when we get
the details we can cut all of these and
say Pokemon and give all these
properties and now we need to extract
these from Pokemon so here we can say
Pokemon and put all of these inside of
there and here what we need to do so if
error else if Pokemon or else if this
dot state dot Pokemon and now we
shouldn't get that day
cannot read property name of no sure
it's just let's just get the Pokemon and
then accesses properties so here we can
just add Pokemon at the start of all of
these so come on dot alright cool we go
we don't get that markup I don't know
what was that about
alright so now we can search for Pokemon
so let's say Pikachu of type search cool
we get the image and we get has our has
without an e has those abilities and if
we just type something in some nonsense
it should say Pokemon not found please
try again and if we try I don't know
some other pokemon snorlax if we type
search go we get Snorlax s image and the
number of abilities and everything so
what's cool about this is that if we
make a typo right here URLs it's gonna
flag it immediately we don't have that
on the type Pokemon which is cool so we
don't have to run and then run into
runtime errors and we can as well have
types for our functions guys so this
doesn't return anything but you can even
be more strict and say void like this
and what's cool is that you can create
some functions let's say or methods on a
create a method called add numbers and I
want this method to take two numbers and
add them so a type number and be of type
number and be not can't repeat an
argument so here we just say return a
plus B now we can strictly say we can
still here say return like hello world
which which is cool but if we say here
that it has to return a number it's
gonna complain now so we can make our
code more safe and more scalable by
having all these type safety mechanisms
implemented through our code so we can
scale up without having to worry about
these little weird
runtime errors and little mistakes
anyway you can expand the functionality
of typescript and make your project so
much more typesafe I guess and more
productive by having all this these cool
functionalities I think it's a cool
technology that everyone should learn
anyway thank you for watching I hope you
learned a lot if you like this video
like it if you didn't like anything if
you didn't like by the way this theme
that I created for myself tell me I'll
revert back to the classic dark plus
anyway thank you very much and I hope to
see you soon bye